hi kate hi hi conan hi thank you for
being here and let me explain
our our trajectory uh to anyone who may
not know
um right after uh the killing of george
floyd we had
two weeks of discussions on my show
trying to just open it up talk to a lot
of different people one of the first
people i talked to
uh was w kamau bell who's uh
a a friend of mine over the years a guy
i know and
and trust and i thought let's let's have
this conversation
and one of the first things he did in
his interview was said conan i'm going
to
assign you what was the word he used a
whiteness counselor i think so i think
he said that i was going to be in charge
of your whiteness
in charge of my whiteness and um first
of all
i thought i pity whoever's in charge of
my whiteness because
that is a lot of whiteness to be in
charge of so much
blinding yeah and then i thought um
i got confused because i thought well
wait is this person you're assigning me
to
if she's there to help me be more white
it's not necessary but apparently that's
that's not what it was all about
and we uh have started up a bit of a
dialogue you and i
and i've been looking through your books
and i'm very impressed
but tell me when uh
when our mutual friends said whiteness
counselor or you're in charge of my
whiteness how did you interpret that
and uh so i interpreted that as you know
it's it was kind of an
offshoot of a conversation that came out
and i had had um you know earlier that
week so
in the in the wake of the murder of
george floyd and
the uprising around racial justice that
we saw
and experienced and are still
experiencing come out
texted me and said you know basically he
was like hey
all these rich powerful white people
with tons of privilege keep asking me
what do i do
uh and he was like i don't know what to
tell them can i send them to you is
there like a website y'all have
like for white people like what what do
i do with them and i wrote them back and
i was like yes send them my way
come out of course like you don't need
to deal with that right now i did not
expect the first person uh for him to
send my way to be you
yes it happened immediately and it's the
worst news you ever got
you know it was great and and you know
but what i really saw
was was an opportunity to do what i
think i've always tried to do which is
you know leverage my platform and my
privilege to make some kind of impact
um whether it's through books or through
uh teaching which i did for many years
or through just having conversations so
i
thought well i've got a lot of new
followers on twitter and on instagram
um and i really believe that in this
particular moment
white people have a lot of questions and
and
they deserve to be able to ask them um
they're all great questions no but
there's a lot of confusion and they're
there and is still a lot of what do i do
what's the most effective thing to do
what's happening
um those questions don't need to be
directed necessarily to
your black friends and colleagues and
neighbors um so i was like well i'll
just get on
instagram and ask people to send me
their questions and we'll just start
talking
and i got hundreds of questions i still
do
um and i've been doing my best to answer
them um
honestly